oh honey you made your solo performance
debut yeah
and people are raving about it i talked
to come on yes you don't overhear sister
and look even we're rocking a mess
supporting yourselves huh
[Music]
you both look stunning what did you
think of oh my gosh what did i think
i didn't even think you could ask me
that because i think we all collectively
as the world were just dying
[Applause]
[Music]
what did it feel like to get up on stage
and finally
perform for the first time solo it felt
insane like i lost feeling in my legs
i'm still trying to regain them back now
if i hadn't moves like yours i've been
losing feeling in my legs too
yeah so i'm still coming off a high yeah
yeah you check social media yet because
a little bit a little bit and
everyone is going crazy
so what's next for you from here
more love and light and enjoying life
and seeing where that goes you know
she's so humble about all of this girl
you want a big thing thank you very much
yes she is indeed what a beautiful duo
right here have fun tonight y'all